well this weekend is Easter but for the
first time in America's history the
country's Christians will not be able to
celebrate it with one another even if
they want to most governments this
country will not allow them to gather in
churches Mississippi is under lockdown
all essential non-essential businesses
are closed that means the liquor stores
of course are still open they're
essential churches are not essential
according to the state King James Bible
Baptist Church has been trying to hold
drive-in services that means prisoners
remain in their cars during it but cops
showed up anyway and raided it the Kings
ain't by a babbler what pastor Hamilton
where I'm the pastor the church at I'm a
good citizen
ain't breaking no law ain't selling no
drugs I'm just preaching the Word of God
and look all the police car here that
was pastor James Hamilton you heard on
the tape we're happy to have him on with
us tonight along with Kelly Shackelford
president of the first Liberty Institute
thanks so much for coming on both of you
first to you Pastor what exactly were
you doing wrong wrong we was abiding by
the CDC guidelines that the City of
Greenville have put in place also the
state of Mississippi members of the
church was inside their cars had the
windows up and I was preaching the Word
of God so no one was outside and also we
had cars at a distance and so legally we
wasn't doing anything wrong we was going
by the CDC guidelines and so I don't
understand why the police amplicon to
our church and try to break it up
well it's totally outrageous Kelly
Shackelford I assumed that when this
happened every civil rights group in
America jumped to the pastor's defense
right I don't know about that we
certainly did the order that's in
Greenville
it's just massively unconstitutional it
targets churches in a way that it
targets no other group so park cars and
parking lots are fine it's only a crime
if the cars in the parking lot are at
the church parking lot
and I mean look at last night you had
probably six seven or so cars there for
the church and yet they were surrounded
by police and I don't know if you saw
the video Tucker but one of the police
officers came up to pastor Hamilton and
said that because of these orders
because of that local order in
Greenville Mississippi that his rights
were suspended those are the specific
words he used like you your
constitutional rights are gone now I
don't know what country he thinks he's
living in but your rights aren't
suspended and I would just tell any
church that has any of these issues or
what we have a lot of this information
go to first Liberty or get just spell
out first Liberty it'll tell you that
you do have rights that we want to
follow the CDC guidelines we don't want
people to be injured in any way and
that's what this church gives that
doesn't give people the right to
discriminate against churches and treat
them in this kind of way well of course
it doesn't so pastor I mean I I'm not
against liquor stores but liquor stores
don't answer the question what happens
when you die which is something maybe
you'll be nice to know now the people
are dying from this pandemic how do you
feel that liquor stores get to continue
but you can't celebrate Easter in church
think of it like this I believed in
liquor beer have killed more people than
the corona virus would and so the sad
case in America who ever thought that we
would have our government in green beer
that would pass such a law that will
allow the liquor stores to have curbside
service well but we've come to the
church and trying to disrupt our church
service I would have never dreamed in a
thousand years the America the home of
the Braves and the land of the free
whatever pass this law that would
consider a liquor store central but
Church not a central shop so eighty
seven thousand Americans died of alcohol
last year this epidemic is projected to
kill 60,000 so you're absolutely right
technically factually you're right I
just want to go out on this I would like
to know and if you know the name I hope
you'll say it on the air who made this
decision did let liquor stores get a
pass but hassle your church with armed
police officers who what politician
decided that was a good idea pastor Eric
Simmons
he's a man he's uh he's a supporter of
Joe Biden he made a decision that
because most of the buyers was coming in
was linked to he said to the churches so
that's why he came down very hard on the
churches to not have drive-in services I
can tell you when 20-plus cars came to
our church we felt not just mean we felt
intimidated
we felt frightened and I heard about
this in China I heard this about income
this country but I would never thought
that I would feel so afraid and my
people will feel so slightly intimidated
by police officers so you hear about
civil rights violations this is an
actual civil rights violation faster
thanks so much for coming on Kelly
Shackelford - appreciate your coming -
thank you
Thank You Tucker